a victory for anti-government protesters
as police abandoned their posts to join
the demonstrations just days ago the
groups clashed now they stand side by
side the rebellion poses a new threat to
Evo Morales South America's longest
standing leader under the framework of
democracy and the law the armed forces
guarantee union among our countrymen
therefore we confirm that we will never
confront the people to whom we have a
duty and we will always ensure peace
coexistence and the development of our
homeland
Bolivia's ruling party responded by
calling on supporters to defend the
results of the contested election
Morales is rejecting calls for his
resignation insisting the vote was fair
you know then I want to denounce to the
Bolivian people and the whole world that
a coup d'etat is underway as you know
brother journalists a coup d'etat
against a democratically elected
government with more than 60% of the
vote in the last elections all others in
devotion to the luteal excuse a coup
d'etat by violent anti-democratic groups
that don't respect democracy the
election results or social peace
Morales also blamed organized opposition
groups for setting fire to the homes of
his sister and two governors this after
protesters occupied two state-run media
outlets on Saturday an electoral audit
by the Organization of American States
is underway
the opposition has already said it will
not accept the results